Sky News understands that the police
search of an area in Portugal near where
Madeleine McCann went missing 16 years
ago has now come to an end the search
had already been extended from two days
to three now Europe correspondence
Cheval Robbins is at the scene of the
search and can bring us the latest
Siobhan
yes the searches you say appears to have
ended to bring people up to date we've
been here over the last two days and at
this Reservoir and the peninsula behind
us that's where we've been seeing the
main Hub of the action that's been going
on here so we've seen for example
sniffer dogs being brought in cutting
machines clearing wooded areas drones
going up police officers digging and
this was all on the request of the
German authorities who have named their
prime suspect in The Disappearance of
Madeleine McCann in 2007 as a convicted
sex offender called Christian B now it's
understood that they asked for these
searches which have been done as a joint
effort by the German authorities the
Portuguese and with some officials from
the UK the reason they asked them we
understand is because they got a
credible tip-off from an informant
Christian B has always denied any
involvement but it's thought that he
used to visit this place so they've been
back here and over the course of this
day we've seen a lot of the heavy
machinery uh that was used in those
searches coming out we've also seen down
the road an HQ which was set up with
various blue tents that's all come down
now and we put in a request to the
German prosecutor to see what was
happening and he said to us that the
fact that the search teams seem to be
leaving that everything is packing up
would suggest that the search is over
but important to underline that doesn't
mean the investigation is over because
what they need to do now is look at
anything that they may have found here
find out if it moves the investigation
on or if it's something to discard and
then also continue to investigate what
happened to Madeleine McCann now we're
hoping to get some sort of confirmation
that the search is officially over
although from what we can see it clearly
is and also maybe later in the future
find out from those prosecutors if they
have found anything credible to move
this investigation forward
and Siobhan I know you're there a remote
Reservoir in Portugal but you know um
such is the focus of attention still on
Madeleine McCann's 16 years on what's
been the level of interest on what's
been happening there over the last three
days
huge it's been absolutely huge as you
say this is a remote area it's a place
where signal is difficult winding roads
and all of the roads are absolutely
packed with vehicles there have been
people bringing in Satellite trucks
there have been Crews from around the
world here and we went to Pride I luge
which is where Madeleine McCann
disappeared appeared from in 2007 and
it's what people there are talking about
as well we spoke to tourists who have
been coming back to this area for
decades who were in the area at the time
when Madeleine McCann disappeared and
they said everyone's talking about it
it's on the front pages of the
Portuguese newspapers and for the the
tourists that we spoke to certainly they
feel like this is a new opportunity
really to get answers because this
search that's been happening is the
first one back here in Portugal for
almost a decade and there's a feeling
that hopefully there'll be answers for
the family in due course but also for
the people living in this area where the
case has just hung over them for 16
years